good morning hope every had a nice
evening and good conversations last
night it's great to be have you here
again I'm Matthew Spalding associate
vice president Dean for wash for
Hillsdale here in Washington DC I don't
know about you but I did my normal
routine this morning and read the papers
and it's getting harder and harder to
keep up with things in this town as it
goes sometimes increasingly crazy and
some things are going that are going
very well what I find interesting is
when you step back and think about last
campaign and that's presidency and it's
kind of disruption of a lead opinion it
actually reveals things in many ways
almost more than what it actually is
doing it to cover this like it pulls
back the curtain that's really clear on
the left the other day I was reading New
York Times doing a little opposition
research and the the guest editorial not
the columnist but they guest editorial
for the New York Times was writing about
how the the main social aim right now
must be a formal restructuring of the
American constitutional system and this
guest editorialist
was the editor of the Jacobin which is a
socialist newspaper Oh after you would
look no further than the Cavanaugh
hearings to see that olinsky's rules of
rules for radicals seems to be driving
their cause things are also revealed on
the right as well pulling back that
curtain about their thinking and the
coherence of conservatism how they acted
it adjusted in these circumstances is
this a brush breath-of-fresh-air or is
this macbeth how do we think about this
but of course this is not necessarily a
new question these are actually old
questions what are the first principles
of our political thinking what are the
grounds of that thinking and how do they
guide us in new and different times both
of our panels this morning deal and
address that kind of a question stepping
back and thinking through what's going
on
in different different areas our first
panel this morning is being chaired by a
friend and colleague of mine at the
college Ronald distrito but let me
preface by saying that the Van Andel
School of statesmanship has accomplished
an amazing and great and significant
thing for our country largely because of
him he's the driving force behind it
they recently graduated their first PhDs
and if you understand the importance of
ideas in shaping how we think about our
future you realize that's extremely
significant he's the Dean the Graduate
School sage super Hillsdale College and
holds the Charles and Lucia Shipley
chair in American constitutionalism he's
also a great scholar especially of the
Progressive Era and has written Woodrow
Wilson in the roots of American
liberalism and has edited a collections
writings winner Wilson the essential
political writings I give you are G of
history
Thank You Matthew good morning everybody
it's our first panel today's program and
the topic of the panel this morning is
libertarianism and its relevance in
politics today so on the one hand
libertarianism certainly doesn't seem to
poll very highly in American politics
candidates identifying themselves as
libertarians aren't winning office in
any and any great number on the other
hand I think one could argue that the
state ISM that we saw of the in the
Obama years has kind of pushed
Republican politics
in a libertarian direction this has also
had an effect on the conservative legal
philosophy as many on the right we now
see them calling for a much more
activist judiciary than say one could
have predicted 10 or 20 years ago so
this is an interesting question we have
three very distinguished panelists to
engage on the question I will introduce
each panelist when it is his turn to
speak we're going to begin with Randy
Barnett professor Barnett is the carmack
waterhouse professor of legal theory at
the Georgetown University Law Center
he teaches constitutional law and
contracts there he's also the director
of the Georgetown Center for the
Constitution mr. Barnett's most recent
book is titled our Republican
Constitution securing the Liberty and
sovereignty of We the People in 2004 he
argued the medical marijuana case of
Gonzales v Raich before the Supreme
Court and in 2012 he was one of the
lawyers representing the NFIB in its
constitutional challenge to the
Affordable Care Act
welcome Randy Barnett
well thank you RJ it's a great pleasure
to speak again at Hillsdale Colleges
Constitution Day celebration as well as
to share the program not only with RJ
Crist Rito whose work I greatly admire
but with with FH Buckley and our Reno
although it makes me think that I should
start calling myself Ari Barnett from
now on this must be some secret cabal
code that I have that was not shared
with me I'm just using my actual surname
very radical I'm the radical on the
program as the as our topic this morning
is is libertarianism politically
relevant which may strike you as an odd
topic for a constitution day program but
I'm gonna roll with it because that's I
was that's what I was invited to talk
about as the only libertarian on the
panel I think that's safe to say
it falls to me to define libertarianism
for our discussion which I believe I can
do in two sentences two sentences so the
first sentence is this all men are
created equal and are endowed with
certain unalienable rights that among
these are life liberty and the pursuit
of happiness the second sentence is this
that to secure these rights governments
are instituted among men deriving their
just powers from the consent of the
governed that my friends is
libertarianism in a nutshell of course
it also happens to be the words of the
Declaration of Independence now I don't
need to remind a Hillsdale College
Gathering that the Constitution is not
our founding document the Declaration is
the declaration officially identified
the political theory on which the United
States was founded I stress officially
because this theory was drafted by a
committee edited by the Congress as a
whole and unanimously adopted by
representatives of the thirteen
it was the official theory of why the
colonists were justified in separating
from and resuming a state of nature with
Great Britain it was only after this
official act that what the Declaration
refers to as a form of government was
then established first by the Articles
of Confederation and later by the
Constitution and these two
constitutional structures were adopted
as memes to the end of government
identified by the Declaration and the
end is the protection of the natural
rights to life liberty and the pursuit
of happiness although I myself prefer
the canonical formulation of natural
rights that was drafted by George Mason
for the Virginia Declaration of Rights
it read all men are born equally free
and independent and have certain
inherent natural rights of which they
cannot by any compact deprive or divest
their posterity among which are the
enjoyment of life and liberty with the
means of acquiring and possessing
property and pursuing and obtaining
happiness and safety
Mason's canonical formulation of natural
rights was included in the
Constitution's of five states
Jefferson's version was adopted only by
New York nor was this language merely
hortatory and unenforceable Mason's
formulation in the Massachusetts
Constitution was used by its supreme
court to hold that slavery was
unconstitutional in that state Mason's
formulation was also the core of Justice
Bushrod Washington's
influential Circuit Court opinion in
core field versus Coryell explaining the
meaning of privileges and immunities
that are protected by article for
Washington's definition of privileges
and immunities was in turn heavily
relied upon by congressional Republicans
in the 39th Congress to explain the
meaning of privileges or immunities as
it appears in the Fourteenth Amendment
notice that the rights of life liberty
and the pursuit of happiness to which
the Declaration refers and the natural
rights to the enjoyment of life and
liberty with the means of acquiring and
possessing property and pursuing and
obtaining happiness and safety to which
Mason's declaration refers are all
individual or personal rights they are
not collective or communitarian rights
and the purpose of government the only
purpose of government on this account is
to secure these personal rights the
declaration says nothing about enforcing
a code of personal ethics or morality
enforcing the rights of the community or
enforcing a right of a political
majority to impose its will on a
dissenting minority it speaks only of
securing what the ninth amendment refers
to as quote the rights retained by the
people the declaration also infer also
affirms that governments are not to be
confused with the people themselves
governments are instituted amongst us
government's are not us and indeed the
Declaration expressly distinguishes
between the government and the governed
when the Declaration speaks of the
consent of the governed it is speaking
of the people of the United States
consenting to be governed by Great
Britain or by a government of the United
States it is not claiming that a
majority of some subset of the people
who are designated legislators can
consent to laws that then violate the
fundamental rights of the sovereign
people on whom those laws are imposed
rather it says that governments derive
their just powers from the consent of
the governed according to this passage
legitimate governments may exercise not
all powers not unlimited powers but only
their just powers a just power is one
within the competence of a legitimate
government which the declaration defines
as one that secures the natural and
inalienable rights of We the People each
and every one of us
now some of you may have noticed that I
omitted the words by their creator when
I quoted the declaration but do not be
dismayed I did this only because my
purpose was to define libertarianism and
because libertarianism is a political
theory as a political theory
libertarianism takes no particular
stance on whether these inalienable
natural rights are endowed by a Supreme
Being or are instead simply the
essential prerequisite of successfully
achieving a society in which individuals
may pursue their own happiness while
living in close proximity to that is in
society with others who also have
inalienable natural rights libertarians
who believe in natural rights do not all
agree on the justifications for those
rights which brings me to an important
caveat rightly understood libertarianism
is a political theory not a moral theory
morality instruction a morality
instructs us on how each of us ought to
act and libertarianism is not a theory
about that libertarianism is a political
theory of governance and it claims that
government exists to protect individual
rights and must be structured in such a
way as not to violate the very rights it
has been empowered to protect but
although the protection of natural
rights the natural rights of we the
people from foreign and domestic threats
is the ultimate end of government as I
explained in my book the structure of
liberty justice and the rule of law
these rights are themselves merely means
to the higher end of enabling each
person to pursue happiness while living
in society with with others as an
Aristotelian natural law adherent myself
I think natural law ethics tells us how
to exercise the bounded individual
liberty that is defined and protected by
natural rights
so while libertarianism makes no claim
about how people should exercise the
freedom that is defined by their natural
rights
what libertarianism does claim is that
first come rights and then comes
government the Declaration of
Independence shows this to be the
officially adopted American theory of
government as I have now defined
libertarianism then the question before
us is this is the American theory of
government politically relevant today I
think we can all agree that the American
theory of government has been in trouble
for a very long time were this not the
case Hillsdale College would not be the
distinctive place that it is slavery was
a great departure from the American
theory of government before the Civil
War
Jim Crow was a great departure for a
hundred years afterwards the rise of
progressivism as a political movement in
the late nineteenth century led to many
more departures the Supreme Court has
not covered itself in glory in adhering
to the American theory of government it
aided slavery before the Civil War in
cases like pretty versus Pennsylvania
and Dred Scott vs. Sanford it abetted
Jim Crow by gutting the Fourteenth
Amendment in cases like the
slaughterhouse cases in US v Cruikshank
and after an initial resistance it
acquiesced to a progressive vision of
government beginning in the 1920s and
proceeding up to today to the extent
that restoring the lost Constitution the
title of another of my books by
nominating judges who adhere to the
original meaning of the text is
politically relevant today then so too
is the American theory of government
that comprises the core of
libertarianism and I believe we can all
be heartened by the fact that this
administration unlike its Democratic and
Republican predecessors is making the
appointment of originalist justices a
priority if judge Kavanagh becomes
justice Cavanaugh a majority of the
conservative majority on the court
we'll be self-described original public
meaning originalist who take it to be
their mandate to uphold laws that are
consistent with that meaning and
invalidate laws that are not so for this
reason if no other libertarianism is
highly politically relevant today now I
figure some of you are saying that I've
loaded the dice here you to believe in
the Declaration and you aren't a
libertarian well that may be true but it
may not be true
you may call yourself a conservative but
really be a libertarian at heart after
all
self-described libertarians do not agree
amongst themselves about everything
there are more moderate and more radical
libertarians but all libertarians agree
that governments must respect the rights
retained by the people and libertarians
have thought about that who have thought
about it understand that a person's
Liberty may reasonably be regulated to
prevent the violation of other person's
rights the question is what else besides
what the declaration instructs do you
think government should do if you think
in addition to securing these rights
government should also mandate moral
behavior that does not violate the
rights of others you might be a
conservative or you actually might be a
progressive depending on which morality
you think government should impose on
the people if you think that government
exists to promote social justice then
you most certainly like that you're most
likely to be a leftist in short contrary
to your intuition libertarianism is a
far more modest political theory then
most of the other theories on the left
or on the right that are far more
comprehensive this is because in
addition to protecting the rights
expressed in the Declaration that enable
people to pursue the good they would
also use government to compel them to
live a particular conception of the good
life that's much more ambitious and if
you're a small d-- Democrat the
individual must live his or her life
according to the will of the majority as
expressed by a handful of individuals
who are designated
legislators as I explained in my book
our republican constitution the framers
of our constitution were not democrats
they were Republicans they adopted the
Constitution precisely because they
Accord what Massachusetts delegate
Elbridge Gerry called the excess of
democracy or as governor Morris of
Pennsylvania observed quote every man of
observation has seen in the democratic
branches of the state legislatures
precipitation in Congress changeable
Necedah partment excesses against
personal liberty private property and
personal safety
that sounds pretty libertarian to me and
yet many conservatives today preach a
judicial philosophy in which judges are
supposed to defer to the Democratic
majority in the legislature in the name
of judicial restraint Chief Justice
Roberts justified his swing vote to
uphold Obamacare by quote granting the
Act the full measure of deference owed
to federal statutes unquote because it
was in his words reasonably possible to
construe the penalty enforcing the
insurance mandate as a tax he claimed he
had a duty to do that if that decision
by John Roberts bothers you if you think
he was not doing his duty as a Justice
to hold Congress to its enumerated
powers if you think those powers are
defined by the original meaning of the
text of the Constitution to protect the
natural rights of We the People each and
every one of us and if you think that
laws that violate the original meaning
that original meaning are
unconstitutional and invalid then to
paraphrase Jeff Foxworthy you just might
be a libertarian
and that version of libertarianism is
very much politically relevant today
thank you
okay Thank You Randy our next speaker is
Frank Buckley mr. Buckley is a
foundation professor at George Mason
University's Scalia School of Law his
most recent book is titled
the way back restoring the promise of
America he is a senior editor at the
American Spectator and he has a regular
column in the New York Post and has
written for many many national media
outlets he's also a frequent media guest
he's appeared on programs like Morning
Joe CNN rush limbaugh NPR and many
others please join me in welcoming Frank
Buckley
thank you very much and I'm delighted to
be here a correction the way back was
two books ago the most recent book is
called the Republican Workers Party just
out and it's been described as the
definitive guide to the 2016 election
and who am I to disagree I also want to
thank Randy Barnett I confess that I was
a little apprehensive about coming here
from George Mason if people know
anything about George Mason he was the
guy who refused to sign the Constitution
but Randy reminds us the he also had the
glorious honor of writing the Virginia
Declaration of Rights which was to a
large extent plagiarized by by Thomas
Jefferson so Roberts Trudeau asks us
whether libertarianism is politically
relevant and I confess that had I been
asked that in the past I might have been
a little peeved because I would have
remembered how or elections where you
know the Libertarian candidate got 3% of
the vote and the Democrat won by 1%
right or I might remember how the
libertarian would boast was liberal
friends that really I'm on the same side
as you on all the important issues like
same-sex marriage and abortion and as
for my views on dodd-frank we both know
they don't matter all that much and so
when I think of all of that or when I
thought of all of that I would recall
those terrible words of Oliver Cromwell
you have sat here long enough for all
the good you have done that part I say
and be done with you in the name of God
go
but that was then because more recently
I've realized how utterly irrelevant
politically libertarians are I realized
that as a percent of the electorate they
get about three percent and they split
their vote last time equally between
Trump and Hillary so that's my answer to
the question and politically
libertarianism seems to be utterly
devoid of interest but but that's not
even true that's not a complete answer
because it doesn't begin to describe how
politicians might be influenced by
libertarianism and there been these
glorious libertarian moments in our
politics I'm thinking particularly of
2012 and the distinction that Romney
made between makers and takers a pure
libertarian moment and also the end of
that campaign as you'll recall what
libertarian has contributed to the
Republican Party is largely defeat after
defeat after defeat but but but in the
word of world of ideas we also have to
recognize the good things that the
libertarians have contributed and in
particular my friend Randy Barnett we
can too easily criticize libertarians if
we fail to recognize what they've
contributed if you don't aren't able to
talk intelligently about Henry Manny on
insider trading or Jim Buchanan on
public choice or build Niskanen on
bureaucracy or George Stigler on
regulation then the conservative black
standing to criticize libertarians and
if he tries to do so misses a good
opportunity to remain silent before
there were libertarians there were
Republicans who wanted marginal tax
rates of 91% and before there was Barry
Goldwater there was abduction so on so
many issues conservatives are on the
same side as libertarians for example
the conservative thinks we fears we
might have become a class Society and
he's right but the problem is not free
markets the problem is really the
absence thereof it's the Liberals who
put all the barriers to mobility before
us in terror
excuse me terrible schools and and a
decayed rule of law so I want to say the
libertarians saw a portion of the truth
and an important portion of the truth
but only a portion of the truth and so
now let me do that which I'm here for
which is to dump on libertarians I want
to say three things about them I want to
say first of all that it's it's an
empirically false theory to the extent
that it offers any predictions or
statements about the way the world is
right if you believe that the best
government is the least government then
you're saying you'd like to live in hell
holes like Mogadishu well nobody wants
that and of course the libertarian will
say I don't want that either I want to
live in a classically liberal society
with the rule of law but that wouldn't
work either and I'll tell you who say
who realized that it wouldn't work and
that was Milton Friedman Friedman in the
1990s said look you know Soviet Union
here's what you do it's really simple
you just privatize privatized privatized
and then ten years later after seeing
what happened to Russia he said wait a
minute
I was wrong I realized that
privatization doesn't mean a thing
unless you have the rule of law well
here's the problem for the libertarian
as opposed to conservative now what
we're talking about is what kind of
society produces a decent rule of law
and that's the sort of question that
conservatives who interest themselves in
institutions are better able to answer
than the libertarian who just assumes
that it's handed to you right it's a
conservative will ask questions like can
you have a decent rule of law absent a
virtuous people can you have a decent
rule of law absence a religious people
not the libertarian a libertarian would
never ask that one as Randi noted so the
important question then is how to how to
create a rule of law and the other thing
is this I mean I guess if there's a
prediction in libertarianism it's that
the happiest people will be in the
countries that are not least governed or
not very governed so who are the
happiest people on earth according to
the world happiness report well he
the top five Finland Norway Denmark
Iceland Switzerland so not exactly
libertarian paradises are I mean I don't
say that we're all that free obviously
but I think we're only number 18 so
that's my first problem with
libertarianism secondly I think
libertarian rests on a very thin or
faulty intellectual basis right Randi
quoted the opening words of declaration
right which refer to the self-evident
truths of equality and and liberty but
note how equality precedes Liberty that
is to say you cannot be a libertarian
unless you're an egalitarian now that
must taste ill in the mouth of the
libertarian who prides himself insane I
don't believe in equality but but it's
true because if you want to say that
equality doesn't matter then you're
saying for example that you know the
country could be half-slave and
half-free and that'll work
right but that doesn't work or it might
be 99 T 5% slave and 5% free right and
that doesn't work so the libertarian has
to make its peace with big a latarian
ISM but that's not even the beginning of
the problem because libertarian also has
to explain why it is we are rights
buried I mean you people I think deserve
freedom only why right what is it is it
that for example people have feelings
well that gives rise to a sense of
empathy for other people which is which
is a good feeling but the problem here
is that animals have feelings so if you
say it's all a matter of feeling you're
opening the door to Peter Singer right
if my dog has freedom has feelings it
certainly doesn't deserve liberty and
we're still what would the libertarian
say to people to tell us the unborn
fetus feels pain that's got to be a bit
of an embarrassment so a feelings don't
suffice then next what about our
intelligence right that distinguishes us
from
animals but it also distinguishes us
from each other so what do we do about
the mentally slow right assuming that
some people are intelligent and have
feelings I mean why should I care about
them I mean it is a fact of course that
people have feelings and it is a fact
that people are intelligent more
intelligent than animals but those
existential statements about the way the
world is don't ground any statements
about the way the world should be that's
a famous problem in philosophy
you're smart and that should matter to
me because I don't get it
the libertarian might also say well and
I think Randi hinted at this that
libertarianism amounts to an efficient
of insurance contract that is I should
care about other people because they can
put money in my pocket right that's the
morality of the Clinton cash foundation
so but we're still think about all the
people out there who aren't going to put
money in my pocket I'm referring to the
unborn the dying the refugee most people
in the world they're not I'm not going
to cut deals with them I mean yes it
does make sense that I treat people with
whom I have contracts well you know for
rational self-interested reasons but for
most people in the world
they're not going to do anything for me
so why is it the case that the
libertarian oh well I mean on what basis
can he say that we're all equal and I
will answer you because we're all
created in God's image you know even
Locke understood that so that if you
recognize the spark in another that
links him to God you're actually
practicing your religion as well as
following the dictates of your religion
and that's how you get across the is
thought problem the the naturalistic
fallacy as philosophers call it and
finally I say that libertarianism is
morally wanting
randy says this isn't about morality I
say it has to be you can't get rid of it
right the libertarian subscribes to a
political philosophy that denies that
the state has any responsibility to care
for the less well-off sick the orphan I
don't say that means he's morally
callous in fact most libertarians I know
are personally very very generous they
simply make a distinction between
private giving and public giving they
say I will give but the state needn't do
so or perhaps better still shouldn't do
so and the question is whether that
distinction can be maintained and I will
argue that it cannot so if you want to
say that you know the government should
do absolutely nothing that that takes
you to Mogadishu and that's not going to
work
or you can say well we have a thin idea
of the state we should I agree says the
libertarian have the government pay for
aircraft carriers but but not for social
security or health care and I don't
understand that distinction I simply
don't I mean I think the libertarian has
to explain why he'd like to support one
and not the other and I'm still waiting
for that explanation the libertarian
might also say that if the state refuses
to support social welfare that amounts
to a kind of tough love that zeros out
some incredibly wasteful products of the
Great Society things that actually
perverted our sense of morality in many
ways things like the AFDC payments and
there's an element of truth in all of
that but it's easy to come up with
examples where the poor are not going to
be helped if they're simply abandoned to
private charity you know I'll give you
one example medical care for the four
hundred thousand bought Americans with
severe pre-existing medical conditions
and for them might offer a form of
national health but then I'm not a
libertarian right I'm describing by the
way something that all most Americans by
a great majority want and which the
libertarian will say no no a thousand
times no
I mean this is one of the reasons why
libertarians in the Republican party
seemed seem to have given it a bit of a
death wish
and finally this is one thing that
attracted me greatly to Trump I'm a
nationalist as as Trump is a
libertarians aren't nationalists of
course you can see why if you were a
nationalist you'd have to give up things
that libertarians love like open borders
and trade deals that leave Americans
worse off and if you were a nationalist
you'd have to like things that
libertarians hate like us or generous
social welfare program for Americans in
need you'd have to have a sense of
fraternity with fellow Americans and so
I say that if the libertarian were a
little more American he might be a
little less libertarian so let me tell
you
summing up the things that the
libertarians missed you can't be a
libertarian unless you're in the gala
terian you can't be an egalitarian
unless you're a religious believer and
if you're an American nationalist and
egalitarian and a believer you'll have
to rethink your opposition to all forms
of social welfare but if our libertarian
does that and there's always hope for
reclamation of souls he'll recognize
that he's within the mainstream of
modern conservatism in the year 2018 and
we would welcome
thank you Frank our final speaker on the
panel will be rusty Reno
Rusty's editor first things which is one
of America's most influential journals
of Religion and Public Life he was
formerly a professor of theology and
ethics at Creighton University and he is
the author most recently of a book
titled resurrecting the idea of a
Christian society he's also published a
commentary in the book of Genesis as
well as numerous other books and essays
please welcome rusty Reno thank you very
much I lack
brandy Barnett's legal precision and I
certainly lack Frank Buckley's wit but I
will I will give it a shot here on this
question about libertarianism and its
relevance in 2018 first let me begin
with my definition of libertarianism as
a political theory I think it's quite
simple and part of the attraction of
libertarianism is its elegance as its
conceptual elegance and that's this a
society is more just insofar as its
citizens are more free to act and live
in accord with their personal
preferences so we have greater justice
insofar as we have more freedom to live
in accord with our personal preference
the thing is very simple a definition of
justice in this kind of libertarianism I
think resonates in America it taps into
our national culture that prizes
individual freedom there's no question
about that live free or die don't tread
on me it has a natural resonance and
libertarianism also all upholds the
intrinsic value of the individual
something that I think we have moral and
religious reasons to want to do
especially in the modern era when the
individual can so easily be sore as
crushed or controlled by remote
and powerful institutions and so for
these reasons it seems to me
libertarianism will remain a voice of
protest on behalf of the individual and
for some it'll be of vital and cherished
voice of protest but that said it seems
to me that in 2018 libertarianism has
largely become irrelevant to the
challenges that we face we're in the
worst case scenario actually part of the
problems that we face and let me give
three problems or three senses in which
libertarianism is is ill-suited its ill
suited to the crisis of our time which
is a crisis of loyalty and solidarity
not a crisis of crushing collectivism
- Frank Buckley's notion of fraternity
is the crisis not one of collectivism
second libertarianism contributes to the
anti political character of 21st century
social imagination which tends to run in
the direction of technocratic long curry
on the one hand or identity politics and
moralism on the other hand and then
finally the third element it has a
theoretical one-sidedness of
libertarianism as a philosophy of
freedom rather than I would submit a
politics of freedom which I don't think
it provides that it too easily becomes
an enemy of true freedom and limited
government so paradoxically
libertarianism but can become an enemy
of true freedom and liberty and
government so I'm going to go through
these three things crisis of solidarity
not collectivism anti political in its
in its form and unable to sustain true
freedom
so crisis of solidarity not collectivism
right now in 2018 the most powerful
drivers in the West tend toward the
disillusion of traditional communities
including the nation we see this at work
with economic globalization
it's it's at work in the Universalist
ideology of human rights and it's
especially the case with mass migration
European politics today suggest that the
latter mass migration is likely to be
the most disruptive force in the 21st
century now because libertarianism
became to prominence after World War Two
as an answer to the threats of
totalitarianism it offers no conceptual
tools with which even to analyze the
political cultural nature of our actual
challenges in the 21st century because
these are all challenges that tend to
weaken the state and for that matter to
weaken all not all forms of collective
life rather than to strengthen it
so it just libertarianism wants to
weaken the state to protect the
individual but the actual era in which
we live in the crisis is the weakening
of the state and that this is going to
probably define our politics and for the
rest of my lifetime second element
depoliticized imagination politics is an
undertaking of the collective we it's
part of the American genius to have made
the limits on politics into a supreme
and noble act of collective political
power as the great document of limited
government begins the Constitution of
the United States we the people in its
most extreme forms libertarianism
regards any collective action as an
enemy of freedom and so in that sense
the we is always to be resisted
now elaborate libertarian has more more
moderate forms and in this moderate
libertarianism rejects the use of state
power to articulate or embody the first
personal person plural that as I say the
we mean whether it's a whether it's a
moral we just
Oracle we any kind of we I think even
moderate libertarianism wants to reject
the use of state power to articulate or
embody it in both cases libertarianism
like its Enlightenment sibling communism
urges a utopian anti-politics both seek
the withering away of the state and the
establishment of plenary individual
freedom from the coercive power of the
we so Marx remarks the end of history
would be we'd be free to fish in the
morning and read poetry in the afternoon
so we would be free even from we'd be
free from economic necessity as well as
being even free from natural necessity
and that's a kind of plenary freedom
that I think fits the libertarian
definition a society is more just
insofar as its citizens are more free to
act and to live in accord with their
personal preferences I think this is a
this is a shared vision with with
Marxism and in this sense conservatives
are correct when they speak of today's
multiculturalism as cultural Marxism for
its logic is anti traditional it
reflects a desire to break down the
power of our inherited accounts of the
we and now of course it's easy to think
of multiculturalism also as cultural
libertarianism it's very easy to make
that flip to see it as a therapy of
critique for young people that frees
them from preconceptions about their
identity so that they can choose for
themselves who they are and what their
preferences are so multiculturalism is a
kind of forum anarchism in the in the
kind of classic xx early 20th century
sense and transgenderism offers the
obvious example of where the Marxist
inspired critiques of traditional
categories you know sort of Marxist
inspired feminism dovetails neatly with
libertarian aspirations towards a more
perfect human freedom
even to the point of deciding one sex
now few of us are Frankfurt School
inspired mark multiculturalists or for
that or strict libertarians but I would
submit that all of us tend to
participate in the ante and the ante
politics of these very modern and
utopian ways that these utopian ways of
thinking encourage for for a variety of
reasons the political culture of the
West has become very economistic and
utilitarian on the one hand and very
moralistic an absolutist on the other
hand I think immigration is a kind of
classic flashpoint for this where you
have economic arguments about
immigration and human rights arguments
about immigration that tend to dominate
the way we talk about is very difficult
for us to then formulate us a discussion
about immigration based on who we are as
a nation and what kind of immigration
best serves our heritage as America and
American people I mean not the economic
arguments about immigration help us
formulate that nor do the human rights
arguments about immigration help us
formulate in fact they tend to block us
from making those kinds of arguments
neither these tendencies can articulate
a common good neither of them can
conceptualize the cultural political we
that is always the creative subject of
political life now libertarianism here
tenza to tempts us to view the crisis of
solidarity or the diminution of our
sense of fraternity it tempts us to view
this as a kind of end of history
blessing freeing us from the constraints
of the we so that we can be more free
rather than as a deep threat to the
cultural and political achievements of
the West if there is no we how are we
going to sustain the cultural and
political achievements of the West as
Samuel Huntington recognized at the end
of his life the most important
shouldn't we face is a political
question who are we who are weeds the
great question that we face in 22 for
21st century America after you know a
very large wave of immigration beginning
in the 1960s and I believe it's a
question that we can answer we can
answer it together successfully but it's
not a question that libertarianism can
help us ask it can even you can't even
formulate it for us final point about
the true nature of freedom and limited
government the systems of checks and
balances in our Constitution establish
does far more to limit government power
and protect individual freedom than does
the Bill of Rights in much the same way
the deep loyalties that bind citizens
together in religious and civic
institutions and most important of all
bind them together in marriage and in
stable domestic households these serve
as powerful checks against the tendency
of the state to invade and colonize
every aspect of modern life it's it's
the parents defense of the kitchen table
that does much more to preserve freedom
from government control than any
parchment of of Rights the diminution of
all these loyalties over the last two
generations has atomized
our society as Alexis de Tocqueville
recognized isolated individuals feel
vulnerable not only are they incapable
of resisting state power because of
their isolation of vulnerability but in
fact they will demand the expansion of
the state to administer more and more
aspect aspects of their increasingly
dysfunctional lives
it is not coincidental that the julia of
the 2012 obama campaign ad was a single
woman with a child she she needs the
state because she does not have the
finding loyalties religious
and marital isolated atomized
individuals are also acutely vulnerable
to cultural tyranny without shared
loyalties that's different the spine and
without a solid place to stand to
weather the torrents of shame that are
heaped upon them the free individuals
championed by libertarians quickly
capitulate it's one of the importances
of Hillsdale College is that gives young
people a place to stand together which
is what we need to do is to stand
against the cultural tyranny of our time
now my libertarian friends see tyranny
everywhere and they are not mistaken we
live in a time of shocking conformism
and punitive political correctness but
isn't important to recognize that we
also live in a time of unprecedented
personal freedom next to nothing is
obligatory in 2018 other than the
obligation to refrain from making
anything of Lyga Tory now this
combination of bondage and permission
which i think is our culture today we
have a culture of permission and a
culture of bondage is not a paradox
freedom begins with the capacity to say
no say no to worldly powers to say no to
governmental powers economic powers and
cultural powers and we can only say no
insofar as we are formed in accord with
deep shared loyalties fraternity is the
foundation of freedom as the founders of
our country recognized a culture of
freedom requires solidarity we either
hang together or we hang separately the
struggle for independence is always a
political undertaking and it's a
never-ending undertaking the struggle
for independence we have done we have to
continue in that struggle and it depends
upon the strength of the we now
libertarianism like its sibling Marxism
is a Universalist ideology and thus at
the end of the day is always an enemy
of the weed which is necessarily rooted
in the what is particular and historical
the crisis of the West I would submit
which we are which we are we are in the
midst of is it stems from the loss of
the we that loss is eroding our
political capacity to transmit and
protect our cultural inheritance which
is one of freedom so you know I want to
conclude here with libertarians like to
be very logical and which I always
admire it's one of the attractions of
libertarianism it's very rigorous
conceptually so I'm going to end with
the syllogism to encapsulate the failure
of libertarianism so it's a facility ISM
to feel free if you'll forgive me first
premise democracy requires civic
friendship or solidarity requires
fraternity Civic friendship second
premise civic friendship or solidarity
requires a modicum of unity in shared
loves third premise libertarianism
refrains from promoting shared loves and
it's more extreme form it it treats
shared loves as threats to freedom
conclusion therefore libertarianism
undermines the conditions for sustaining
our democratic culture thank you
[Applause]
so I'm been trying to figure out a
takeaway from the panel thus far
professor Barnett tells us that our
founding fathers were libertarians and
that we who love the founding are also
all libertarians our other panelists
have suggested that libertarianism is
akin to Marxism transgenderism and that
libertarians seem to take the light and
wanting to throw the sickest Americans
out on the street what are we to make of
this I thought before we went to
audience questions that I would give the
panelists just at least a minute or two
to offer some additional remarks and
maybe we'll start with Randy thank you
well I have way more that I could say or
would like to say than I would have time
in a minute or two and I would be and I
would begin with all the things that I
agreed with that the other that Frank
and rusty said I agree I would say with
really most of what rusty said and a lot
of what Frank said and that would take a
long time to explain why I agree with
that thing but I so what can I say in a
minute or two that would that would be
at all responsive given all that I think
a couple things first what you didn't
hear from them is how government is
supposed to provide the ends that they
think we need that I agree with them
that we need
you didn't here for them an explanation
of how a government that's powerful
enough to provide a sort of moral vision
that they have in mind is not also
powerful enough to provide an opposite
moral vision that they would find
abhorrent there's got to be an answer to
that you can't just hypothesize a
mythical government that's going to give
you all the right answers that would
make government into a god and that's
something that the look that we as
Americans try not to do and so we didn't
hear anything about that this magic
government solution to provide these
things that we all agree a good
society needs so I'd have to there's
just that that's missing now morality
used to be or and religious morality in
particular used to be comprehensive it
used to be a comprehensive theory that
required government involvement in order
to make a good society this is what
religious establishments were they if in
fact in order to live a good life you
have to not only be good yourself but
you have to be in a community where
everybody else is doing the right thing
and living the right way then you have
to have an established religion to
ensure that everybody is living the
right way and of course we know what
happened as a result of that we had the
persecution of heretics we had religious
wars in which millions of people were
killed and eventually that we had to put
a stop to that and Locke wrote his
theory of toleration on the ground
making the argument that what we need to
do is we need to decentralize the
decision making out of what religion we
have to the level of conscience because
of a right of conscience and each person
gets to decide what religion they have
it's a decentralization of the most
ultimately important decision that
anyone has to make and it meant that
religion itself had to change in order
to be consistent with the notion of
religious toleration that was a very
very important move and then lock in his
letters on toleration backs that up he
says in order for that to work then each
person has to have a kind of moral
jurisdiction over things like property
and other sort of thing in other words
property rights in Locke's letters on
toleration were subordinate to the need
for religious diversity which meant
moral diversity because the alternative
was a Hobbesian war of all against all
we haven't gotten an answer from either
of the other two eloquent speakers as to
how the war of all the Hobbesian
political war of all against all can be
avoided if you try for what's sometimes
called a corner solution to impose your
preferred moral outcomes on everybody
because they are in fact obviously the
right outcomes in fact what Locke I
think showed is that Liberty or
decentralized
based and down to the level of our
individual rights which are bounded not
unlimited but bound
liberté decentralized down to that level
is everybody's second best solution
first best solution is get the moral
morality right the way you think it's
right but then that risk being having
someone else's morality imposed upon you
which is terribly wrong so second best
solution is we decentralize to the
extent possible down to the level
individuals now again in the interest of
time let me just say something in
response to Frank that's sort of more or
less in response to rusty but in both
but in response to Frank Frank says that
libertarians need to explain first of
all libertarians need to believe in
equality well libertarians do believe in
equality that's not a problem
Herbert Spencer a famous libertarian in
the 19th century defined libertarianism
in terms of the law of equal freedom
that's what he called it equality was at
the heart of the concept of
libertarianism but as for libertarians
have an obligation to explain why we
have certain rights I totally agree with
him and you know Frank has written a lot
of books which I admit I haven't read
except for one because Frankie visited
my seminar recent books on the
Constitution and gave one of his books
well I wrote a book which he obviously
hasn't read called the structure of
Liberty Justice in a rule of law because
I believed I agreed with it and I think
it was incumbent to explain why we have
certain rights and I wrote a whole book
to explain it I don't blame him for not
reading it on the other hand my defense
to the answer the question of why is
read my book and you'll see my answer
it's not there and the answer is this
natural I mean the simple answer is this
natural rights are the necessary
prerequisite for individuals to pursue
the good life not to maximize their
individual private preferences the way
rusty is characterizes but to pursue the
good life while living in proximity with
other individuals who themselves have
those rights and whose actions can
adversely affect each other natural
rights are a solution a social solution
to a social problem and it's a claim an
empirical claim that societies who
respect those rights do better than
societies who don't and the other thesis
of my book and now a close going to RJ
is getting antsy is that the rule of law
is essential to the pursuit of justice
justice is defined by rights but the
rule of law is the way we instantiate
justice and that's why the title of my
book is the structure of Liberty justice
and the rule of law because libertarians
in my experience have given too little
thought about the relationship between
the rule of law and justice and that's
what my book attempts to do so who does
read these books well if he hasn't read
my book they all look much of what rusty
has said comes down to a slippery slope
argument I'm not gonna bother try to
respond to that except to say that if it
were the case that signing on to what he
sees as the libertarian Constitution
would make us free then he has to
explain why on measures of freedom we
seem to be dropping like a stone and why
so many other countries are more free
than than we are with very different non
libertarian constitutions but I don't
want to get into that now I want to do
two little things I talked about
nationalism and I want to connect it
with the idea of freedom I want to say
that there's something very distinctive
about American nationalism that is what
makes you American importantly is your
Allegiant to the icons of the ones
American identity which is the
declaration in the Bill of Rights the
Constitution speeches by Abraham Lincoln
so that if you are American you are in
that sense necessarily liberal in the
good old-fashioned sense of that word
and if you're a liberal then you're
somewhat less than American but to
pursue that I want to add that people
will sometimes say about that kind of
thing well that's called creedal
nationalism
that's just signing onto a belief
structure and being American is more
than that right there's an American
culture and I want to say yes that's
that's quite true there is an American
culture it's about the things that we
all enjoy right the things we all share
you know apple pie baseball jazz
country-and-western Aretha Franklin and
so if one is a white nationalist when is
not an American we're too diverse for
any of that if you don't like Johnny
Cash I'm afraid I don't regard you as a
real American okay or you could be a
little bit better therefore there is
something noble about American
nationalism in that it is I think both
necessarily liberal in that good
old-fashioned sense and also generous
with respect to the immense diversity of
who we are as Americans I don't have
problems with that we question I kind of
know who we are
this always comes up when I make
presentations well what if the people
who control the government have a
different view or different moral
cultural view than I do and I just think
that politics is the making of laws to
define defend and transmit a way of life
that is the definition of politics and
we're always tempted I think to try to
come up with a form of politics that
deliver us from the perils of politics
right because it's an ongoing argument
about what our way of life is and we
feel we want to the agony of that
argument is is hard to endure and
modernity has been characterized by
various efforts to escape from politics
that's my sense of anti-politics Marxist
have a theory of history that tells them
where where we are going you know and so
it delivers them from the need to engage
a political deliberation because they
have a scientific theory about history
and the libertarianism in its strict
forms and other other forms of
liberalism in an overly theorized forms
of liberalism also do the same thing so
how can we design our societies such
that we don't have to deliberate about
what our way of life is and I think that
that's that's one of the temptations we
all face is the temptation to try to
escape from that that process of
deliberation thank you I think we're
going to get some questions from the
audience and there are students here
with microphones so it's wait till
you're approached yes stand up I'm
listening to the panelists with rapt
attention is I'm trying to summarize in
my own mind is it fair to say if we
float in the logic say that
libertarianism isn't necessary but
insufficient basis for the good citizen
I would say a love of Liberty as a isn't
necessary but libertarianism know that
that takes a proper love of Liberty and
turns it into the the central rather
than which in our time I just don't
think that that's that's the great issue
that we face the fact is our countries
doesn't mean people our country is less
part imperiled than the European
countries are but they're dissolving and
that that's that's not that's okay as I
say it's a crisis of solidarity
fraternity not a not a crisis of freedom
I I agree with what this questioner said
I that's the reason why I insisted that
libertarianism is a political theory
it's not a moral theory it presupposes
some moral theories perhaps but it's not
one which means it's not enough it's
necessary natural rights are necessary
but by no means sufficient to ensure
either a good citizen or a good Society
and that's my position over here mr.
Buckley if there is broad agreement as
to the nature of rights between
conservatives and libertarians why do we
need to get into the issue of whether or
not there they come from God or get into
the more philosophical deity issues just
be happy and be content with the
agreement as to the nature of what works
capitalism the limited government
private property etc and leave it at
that
well what I said is what I questioned is
why is it you have rights look I don't
know you I mean you seem like a nice
fellow you're here with a Hillsdale
crowd which speaks very well of you but
nevertheless the real question here is
what does this natural right rest on I
mean we've heard a lot about it and I am
saying where the heck did that come from
because it seems to me that it needs
some kind of support and it won't come
from some statement of fact about who we
are and we're intelligent and we have
feelings and all of that I will tell you
I had this experience when I was in
school in grade one the teachers brought
to class
a severely deformed child hydrocephalic
child the parents of the child must have
thought that the experience would be
good for him and from the way he smiled
I think that was correct
our teachers Sisters of Charity must
have thought the experience would be
good for us the students and it is not a
month has passed since then but I've
remembered his face yet counted a shame
that I can't remember his name from them
from him and from the good sisters I
learned something about equality I
learned that if you start with the idea
that we all have souls you rest your
belief in
writes on a much more firm foundation
I'll add one last thing in all my years
in school I don't think from the sisters
I once heard the word writes duty yeah
thank you for everything you've said so
far I'd like to hear mostly from mr.
Buckley anyone could comment on this I'd
like to make you know whether you want
to or not I would like to make some
statements on the beliefs of
libertarianism relevant to a Galit
arianism than your your thoughts
assuming libertarianism accepts atmos
Mis theory of the invisible hand if most
or all individuals provide some benefit
not necessarily financial or monetary to
another individual and if human society
is relatively globalized then it would
be the case that is in the interest of
the individual to protect the same
natural rights of all humans because
most if not all will contribute to the
benefit of most if not all humans
whether one individual provides a net
benefit to another individual we need to
be calculated on a case-by-case basis
and determined subjectively by the
individual as Carl Menger discovered as
as carl menger discovered
lastly important influencers of
libertarianism like Friedrich Hayek
advocated for social safety nets which
would encourage libertarians to provide
for the worst often society thank you
you got the question so can you can you
restate that very concisely it sounded
it sounded like I might have
misinterpreted that you were saying that
an issue with libertarians is that they
are not a gala terian enough that they
would encourage slavery in certain
circumstances so but if but if if they
accept Adam Smith's theory of the
invisible hand that all men can
contribute to the benefit of all other
men then it would be in the libertarians
interest to protect all rights of all
men do you think disagree we got it I
think he was defending slavery the book
was the book which no book more
infuriated Lincoln but in that book and
in the book Fitz you said look slavery
is really a benign institution and if
you were a real philanthropist and
you'll acquire slaves and moreover
only 5% of Americans are the members of
the culture bearing elite who deserve
freedom so you know the prior question
here is why is it that each person
including that hydrocephalic child I
referred to a moment ago why is it
they're entitled to dignity of some kind
or other you see I don't see that as an
empirical matter I mean when Jefferson
said all men are created equal was was
that an empirical statement did that
rest on some basis of fact no it rested
on something very very different and and
unless you go back beyond the Liberty to
that which makes us all equal then
you're spinning your wheels yeah Fitz
you argued that slavery was superior
morally superior system to wage
capitalism wage slavery he called slack
capitalism why because under capitalism
the capitalist owed no duty to the weak
they noted owed no duty to the infirmary
old unlike slaveholders who actually
maintained the well-being of their
slaves from cradle to grave
making slavery a superior moral system
that actually sounds a lot like some of
the arguments I've heard on behalf of
akin so-called conservative I don't know
that I believe it's a conservative
vision of what the government should be
doing only instead of talking about
chattel slavery of African Americans
we're talking about at essentially
enslaving to use Fitzhugh's term a whole
people in order to care for us from
cradle to grave
that was Fitzhugh's argument and it
seems to me that's an argument that has
been adopted rather than rejected by at
least some of what I've heard this
morning from from Frank
I am afraid that's all we have time for
our next panel convenes at 10:30 and I
look forward to seeing you all back for
it thank you very much
[Applause]